this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia.edu okay thank you so I'd like
to welcome you to what we're going to
speak about now is something that we're
working on for the past few months and
we're going to look at the elderly and
the care that we're going to give those
people to the elderly in the future how
many of us have a grandmother
grandfather or anyone over the age of 65
which will be us soon right
unfortunately and what what Westchester
is trying to do is look at how we're
going to take care of the elderly what
do we need to do differently because
right now most people want to leave New
York you go to lengths they don't want
to stay in New York it's too hard it's
too complicated the services are all
over the place they disconnected so how
are you going to connect our people to
each other and that's by developing
livable communities now livable
community says bunch of elders want
simple stuff they want to stay in their
home they do not want to live in a place
where someone's taking care of that they
want to live in their community they
don't want to go someplace else and try
to learn where the post
offices where the supermarket is they
also want to be connected to their
friends so their friends leave New York
then I believe your ball so they don't
want to stay here so what we have to do
in westchester county is make it
inviting make it a place where people
want to stay also they have to stay
healthy if their position is here and
this is true we have a woman that we met
the other week and her position is in
Long Island she travels to Long Island
she doesn't want to then switch over and
get a physician in new rochelle because
once they have a relationship they want
to keep it forever so how do we make
sure that those people in New Rochelle
who want to stay in the show can have
access to their doctor and one of the
main points we're going to talk about is
transportation now what is the livable
community it's a place where you stay
and we make sure that you're active and
healthy and happy now that sounds very
generic and it sounds like all very
simplistic but it's very important to a
person who's looking to stay in their
home until they're what 85 90 years old
we're talking about independent living
and to be connected to everyone else you
may not know this but because of the
baby boom one out of five person in
nourish in westchester county is six
years of age older in 2014 will be one
in four so look how that numbers are
going to jump very soon and that is
going to be devastating to westchester
county if we don't change our act now
currently in westchester county we have
170,000 seniors out of the population of
almost a million now look at this
seniors in Westchester County our older
because a lot of
already there that's why I westchester
county has been chosen to be one of the
places where livable communities will
start we're hoping that this will be all
over this country very soon now look at
another statistic one here almost eighty
percent of those people who are 65 and
older are women who live alone this will
think about the safety and security
issues that those women will have and
what we need to do about that now AARP
is involved in what we're doing for
livable communities and we know that we
want them involved and they said to us
that in 2014-2018 we're going to have a
lot of 85 and older people who are
independently living on their own in
their own homes that are too big for
them and they're going to be
disconnected from everyone else then
going to have no transportation because
in 85 are you driving that's going to be
a problem now what makes a community
livable now the young people in the back
I want you to think about this even at
your age forget that we're talking about
elderly be is a psalm of the components
that you need in your life right to feel
that you can be okay you want affordable
housing you want your parents to be in a
place where they can afford to live now
what happens when I'm 65 and my family
moves away and I'm still in the same
house is it going to be affordable
that's something now for those of us who
have homes think about this if someone
is older and we don't support them are
they going to keep their house stuff are
they going to repair it the answer is no
so then the value of that community goes
down because we as a community that have
not uplifted those who are older so we
want to make sure we support them we
want to make sure that mobility is an
option now this is the leading problem
that we have in New Rochelle because I'm
the Southeast Regional person and a
nervous shell once a person's car is
taken away they can't get to the
they can't get to their friends they
can't even do simple things like go
grocery shopping because in Westchester
County they're getting rid of all the
mom-and-pop stores you have to go to the
big supermarkets where they have
everything there or walmart or walgreens
and you have to deal and and elderly
don't like walk you through all those
animals because that's another issue
they want to walk around they want to go
in there ever they need and leave so one
of the problems that we're having is
transportation so if anyone has any
suggestions we'd love to hear it and
then also we want them to be connected
socially because remember just because
you're old you can still think right
amber you can still process you still
have a lot to give right now these are
the features of a livable community we
want formal informal services what is
that we want to make sure we have access
to our doctors we want to make sure our
social workers are available we want to
get to them we want to be able to get
there and get back we don't want to say
hi I need a ride and go sit in the
doctor's office for five hours while
someone gets off from works and picks
this up we want to be able to come back
and forth safety and security we talked
about that if I'm 85 years old and my
house is 5,000 square feet you know
what's the security issues is my smoke
detectors work who's changing the
battery if you're older you can't change
the battery so you need to have other
people involved in your life to come in
parks and recreation want to make sure
people have access to these things
transportation we talked about the arts
people don't want to just go to the
doctor and shop and watch TV they want
to go out they want to come to mint
they want to go to you know different
events how do they get there they're not
driving how do they get there if their
families are not connected so this is
something that we need to talk about
housing options and of course rose now a
new rochelle think about 95 Lincoln
everyone knows what that is right so
think about where the street is if
you're elderly how do you walk on the
street so you know what the elderly do
in Westchester County and walk in the
street because the street is flat
because they take care of the streets
they don't take care of the sidewalks so
what do we see people pushing with their
carts or they're in a wheelchair and
there in the street going down the road
we see it every day right now what we
want to do is look at some of these
issues for incentives for making a
livable communities now a livable
community is defined in any Church any
synagogue any community center who wants
to vent help and support the elderly
that's what a livable community will be
defined that so how are we going to do
this we're going to make sure that we're
going to heighten the awareness of the
community assets now this is what the
interesting part people in North shell
who are younger than 65 are able to give
services to those who are over 65 and
older now what services suppose I
haven't now we did this with the kids
and we'll talk about that later we did
it elder dial a ride on a election day
when we were looking for who's the guy
next president right before we got
together with the young people and you
talked about how they were going to
offer rides and services to the elderly
so then we had the churches take the
elderly to the polls and then the youth
were there to help them in and out of
the post that's what I'm talking about
intergenerational programs so that's
going to hide
community assets naturally without
costing a lot we want to promote
physical and social environments that
support the lifestyle of the elderly
some people are active some people want
to go to the arm the different
organizations and some people want to go
to the Arts in Manhattan so we have to
make sure we do that and make sure we
get awareness up when a person is living
in their home and they feel safe and
they feel happy then the health is going
to increase because health is based on a
feeling that we have of empowerment not
lovers so if we are in our homes and
when feeling that we can handle we can
go to the dentist right we can go to the
doctor and we can get around then our
health perception goes up we're more
likely going to dentist if I don't have
to call my daughter when those 30 miles
away for my appointment and I want to
come or if my dentist so we have to talk
to health care providers right maybe I
talk to a physician in New Rochelle
maybe we can have a few of them come as
friends and they can join and be
together the doctor to see one at a time
they come together and go home it may be
after that they go shop well they go out
to manhattan or play or something right
this is make sense ok now how do we
measure the mobility this is something
that was done through AARP and they said
what do people take pride in about their
community now does anyone know the
answer to that let's SC on people what
do people take pride in in community
give me ideas when you live in a
community what makes you proud about
when you lift the people around you ok
anything else that's good excellent
answer I'm sorry
how save the environment excellent guess
sanitation excellent anything else see
these are all the components now you're
young they're important to you elderly
this is important to them also and what
they said also is they take pride in
that community where they know who the
neighbors off when they know who the
young people are when they see you and
you talk to them and you interact with
them so if you see someone that has a
lot of snow in their home right and you
know that they don't have a lot of
resources maybe you can help them into a
pathway out of their home so they can
get to the dentist's appointment
doctor's appointment or they are
shopping right so it has to do with
being together and be in a community how
hard will they work to protect their
community assets they treasure very
important if a person is 65 or they
leave to go live in the south or
anywhere else they take the assets with
them don't think and then the community
comes down so then they take their big
their money out their bank accounts they
take everything and they leave and then
the community goes down right so think
about that also you want to make the
community a place where else we want to
stay and live what new accents are they
willing to develop now this is very
important this is for the young people
this comes in with you what are you
willing to do to make the elderly thing
that the community they limit is safe
and secure and has all the components we
talked about and that's what we have to
you know explore and that meat on these
are our stakeholders as you know these
are the people who we're going to talk
to to get our community going now what's
important here is an elected officials
and hospitals very important houses of
worship planners okay planners don't
like the plan places for elderly to live
like in buildings or they don't like
that's not a lot of profit for that
they'd rather put homes and so forth so
we have to talk about maybe leaving
elsley in their homes and something was
done and that was I think it was in
Georgia animals Atlanta where people
were saying I'm an elderly person living
in my home I can offer babysitting
services to single mothers so while so
then they can then in turn live with me
to bribing with my safety and security
right and then they will learn the store
for me so this was some so then the
young person mother needed a place to
live and babysitting while she went to
work right and then they swapped
services and then that worked very well
okay there's other things we can do also
when you looking at schools colleges and
libraries these are places where the
elderly can come in and more for
services right so then these are the
these places should be looking for with
elderly are and ask them to be a part of
it because remember for any person to
feel like they want to stay there they
have to feel connected and a part of
their community otherwise they're going
to want to leave and go elsewhere now
these are the benefit nap and this is
something that we just did recently now
look at this this is how we're looking
at the mapping of the seniors look at
each component and you see that it's a
win-win situation if I'm a nonprofit
organization which I am the seniors can
come in and provide other services right
they can come in and they can help us
develop different plans because these
are very smart and capable people right
and in turn then utilizing their
intelligent they feel needed and wanted
so it's a win-win situation libraries
did you know seniors can provide tax
services for the young who may have not
done to on taxes we have a lot of
college students who have never done
taxes but needs you this maybe they've
worked a part-time job the seniors then
over time to come in and offer these
services when when right look at faith
organizations the elderly can come in
and set up programs in X
whether youth to be involved in and a
young adults and in turn they feel
important they tell their stories that
are connected they bring us all of this
information college and universities
that's easy right we know that seniors
have expertise and experiences we know
that we have learnt in nourish shell
which is learning in retirement it's a
program that should be set up in all
colleges with a senior's come in and
have a day of learning and different
college professors come in and teach
them different things and in turn they
get back to the college and they do a
class so it's a win-win also
community-based organizations the same
thing so then the seniors will give out
this information through senior
buildings because they have a lot to
offer so they're going to say that this
is what we want not community this is
how to promote wellness and then it's a
way when also exactly good as I clear
for everyone now there's five types of
assets to connect to and this is what
we're going to talk about as soon as
I'll be writing this down they're gonna
have a test later okay I know that
regular so there's a talents and skills
other people in the community that's the
natural talents like this gentleman he
does things with coned so then then can
he then offer some services to some
seniors in his area and then in turn
they offer services to his family right
so that could be a win-win so we have to
be creative and think of ways to help
each other and we have to ask the
question what can we do for you because
what happens is a lot of seniors will
sit there quietly and think that we
don't want them to get part of our lives
and that's incorrect we should encourage
them and find them and seek them and
they do need the only issue is they
usually meet during the day when most of
us are working so we have to work out
the time that's that's a problem I'm
having but how do we because they don't
want to come out late so then how do we
get the
together to working and maybe the
weekends or after church we can talk
about that or maybe after any of the
Sabbats right also the physical assets
now they also need to own land and
property in buildings we want to make
sure that we understand what we need to
do to help them keep those those assets
up right so if my windows are not good
maybe because what happens with the
elderly as you know is a lot of people
take advantage of that so they bring
people into their homes to do surveys of
eigen my windows done and that person
even doesn't do the work takes their
money so then they close down and they
get no services for their home because
they're scared to let anyone in or this
end that people are watching them to
seeing when they're home by themselves
so what happens is they're afraid to
keep up their homes because of the
people who might come in and take
advantage of them what's a way to get
out of that to go through the churches
right if I'm at the church and I hear
that and the services i will let him in
because he's part of the church so we
have to link them and connect so they
can be trusted to come in and do the
world okay economic and since we talked
about we talked about that so you need
to make sure local businesses are not
taking advantage of the assets of the
elderly thinking that they need to help
them so for instance there's a gentleman
that I met he makes sandwiches for the
elderly every day because he knows that
they go out and then they're hungry
after the doctors of my cuz they have to
do stuff offenders every week right and
so then he brings and he has them ready
so they don't have to wait and he drops
into their home that's easy so they
don't have to get two trips they don't
have to say can you drop me to the
doctor and then to the place to get the
sandwich because I'm hungry and I don't
have to go home and cook he brings them
to their homes and he has likes done
something good for this population and
then in turn of course they want to stay
and they feel connected okay now getting
to of course the components now we saw
professor Miller today and we know that
there are components to health and
empower
then we use four stages of change
because right away people don't even
know there is a problem they don't think
that the elderly are needed they don't
know the numbers so what happens on the
principles I've designed to put this
model together the same ones I use for
my after-school program so I said it
works for you it can work for the
elderly by getting people involved in
the process by understanding what their
needs are by asking them and by then
having meetings and gather and so we can
all come together and understand what we
need to do and that's what we're doing
out the reason why we're in production
of this program is because it's new it
was just funded from September of last
year so we haven't even been going a
year yet but right now we're doing the
asset mapping and one of the things we
want to do is make sure that we increase
the visibility of those in our
communities because as I said once we
come home from work everyone's in their
home so we have to bring me the two
groups together these are some of the
the connection based opponents we're
going to do planning which is what we're
doing now right right now we are doing
our mission statement we're doing
objectives and strategies we know the LD
have told us we are interested in
transportation right now that's all
they're interested in so we need to fix
that first so they trust us and then we
can move on to other interventions then
we want to also look at the community
and how we can reduce risks one of the
biggest risks we have is the way that
young people drive versus the way the
elderly drive so both are on the road
and there's disrespect in the mind of
the person driving so that always makes
aggressive driving and you have a lot of
l's I tell me you know the young people
are cutting them off so then we want the
police to just encourage young people to
come to classes so they can learn to
share the road because because both
groups do drive differently did you know
both groups have the same number of
accidents the elderly and young people
but what happens when the elderly have
an axe
is the outcome is poor as you know as
you can imagine so we need to encourage
the police and other groups to teach us
all how to share the road because in New
Rochelle we have a lot of young people
driving especially home from school and
that's the kind about the time that they
are you coming back and we have a lot of
accidents occur between three and five
o'clock and afternoon monday through
friday also level of satisfaction has to
be looked at for both groups because we
have a lot we have a great diverse
population in New Rochelle we have all
groups there so going back to what the
doctor said about diversity and cultural
competency we need to take that into
account when people Sabbath this when
they want to road what they need to make
sure because the most devastating thing
happened about a month ago there was an
A&P in a certain area and they had
growing elderly buildings there around
the A&P and if you go in there morning
noon and I or your sors elderly so it
was a real nice place to go I used to go
there they closed it down now guess what
they told the politicians who are trying
to fight to keep it open they said well
we're going to bust the elderly to the
next to supermarket that's you know
that's miles and miles away so guess
what you're seeing now more calls to
those who need lunch programs and and
that kind of service because they're not
going and being bussed anywhere than
just not having any food in their homes
and the and is at least 10 buildings in
that area they have elderly in them in
that malaria because it was surrounding
that little strip where the amt was it
was it was a big AP and the other stores
and now the other stores have said they
bought to revenue because no one's
coming over there and then going to
start closing down see so it just so one
thing just turns into another so we need
to prevent those kinds of things from
happening in the future now getting to
the young people were here today this is
what we're going to do an
intergenerational programs we have for
now what I did was I started with simple
test just so we can get used to talking
to one another elementary school
students which we have some here today
they did the holiday and campaign and
phone calling and greeting so they row
cards to the elderly in the nursing
homes especially and it was interesting
because I teach them that you want to
help someone who'll never say thank you
and if knows about nursing homes never
of course for polis but what happened
was a lot of their relatives came to the
programs and businesses that my heart
got a call from you and we didn't even
know this program was but you know I had
to come over here so then we're
connecting to the family also and see
then the young people are doing
something that is not only good what's
rewarding in another way the middle
school children did the dial a ride as I
told you the high school students though
can do the most because they have the
most mobility now what we're going to do
is some of our students here today we're
looking at mothers and fathers day as a
way to just start off and we're going to
do gifting for our elderly and we're
going to start with our church and then
maybe next year we'll move to other
churches and other nursing homes singing
and and seeing elderly during the
holidays everybody does that already we
want to do something different
throughout the calendar year because
what happens now is we only do things
when there's a holiday so it's
Thanksgiving the feeding if it's Easter
if it's Christmas we want to do
something year-round to have something
different every month so they can look
forward to seeing these young people
every month and that's what we're trying
to do so we're having a big health they
aren't april six if you're new rochelle
please come by at the high school and
we're going to actually for the first
time have the elderly there at this um
health fair so they can then talk to the
young people because this is at the one
high school that we have in your
rochelle and that's what we plan to do
so it's all it's our way of starting off
our anticipating and outcome is
supporting a community that promotes
dignity dignity has to be there we have
to make people know that they are valued
they are important it doesn't matter
what age they are okay independence
and civic engagement of course we want
people involved in the process and the
elderly to vote we know that our
politicians know that so everything I go
to the politicians are all there but we
need the those who work there so we need
to like as I said move the meetings and
of course the ultimate goal is very
simple the seniors in Westeros RC happy
and healthy at home thank you
I'll take any questions
dr. Kim Wofford you know how you saying
about like about the buildings and the
brother season how come like in
Westchester they don't like they don't
like you know knock down all those
abandoned buildings and the tournament
too late he has seriously isn't home to
hospitals why don't they giving it's an
excellent question because what happens
is those who plan and develop a not
interested as I said and helping those
who are need and that's the young the
mothers and eligible there's not a lot
of money or profit in that so what they
do in New York and hopefully they don't
do this in the latter is they leave
these places make it for long periods of
time until they can develop the whole
area and then they wiped out the whole
area and then they you know be develop
it in the you know condos and everything
they want now we can we know God Harlow
and we know that's what already happened
and it can't happen where we live also
so what I would say is you need to keep
writing as young people you can't vote
but you can tell them that you will help
them get reelected if they listen to you
and we need to look at the places that
are making the places because there's a
lot in your shell and I'm now garrn in
and all the others especially and we
need to look at that and think about how
we can utilize it until they decide to
plan because even doing temporary
residency is something that we can look
at because they won't sell it to us
we'll give it to us but they'll let us
utilize it until they figure out there
planning strategy and that would even be
helpful to what we want to do mm-hmm yes
it's not only about the elder care but
like for homelessness and like I was
just saying maybe we could write to like
boys and girls club to have it's over
now if I holidays what we could just you
know have a fundraiser to every school
for them and like not just for like
Thanksgiving and Christmas we know how
people are homes and on the streets like
you can provide food having fun with it
but I clothes that we don't have like
we're nowhere even though it up a
Salvation Army bit like just to help
them up that's why right and that's an
excellent point this young lady says
that you know let's talk about other
times during the year when we can have
activities right but she said something
very important that we want to keep
going right we want to keep involving
keep being interred depended upon one
another to have a better community right
and then also she said something that
you know I did forget to mention that's
very important and thank you member for
reminding me about it that think about
it senior centers are used from ninth
grade boys & girls clubs are used from
three to nine so we need to like bring
the two groups together because what
happens is the senior centers are closed
so why can't you go into senior centers
and be a part of that for parents who
need a place for their children to go
and then boys and girls look why can't
they be used during the day for the
elderly because they got poles and they
have places to ride and they have so you
need to rethink that because we close
those 20 down until that group is
available and that doesn't make any
sense so the first thing that we're
working on is opening them up so they're
open all day long so that both groups
can utilize them together and separately
question how are we supposed to interact
with the elderly women like you don't
get to connect with them alive good
question and that is definitely a
problem we're not connecting because we
have in
right elderly don't reach in because of
a lot of reasons of security and safety
and if they read the paper and watch the
TV they they're afraid and you know in
the media plays into the fieran so it
just it breaks down our community
because you know i know that when the
young people look at us you know we were
young a million years ago of course to
their mind but we had elderly watch us
and make sure we were okay even if they
weren't related they could have been the
woman next door but she knew who's
Charlie were as you watch doing that in
trouble I knew you would her house and
something so we look more connected
we're more disconnected now because we
don't know so how do we hope to answer a
question how do we become involved by
meeting with each other by doing
activities insert you know
intergenerational and to become part of
each other's lives yes another question
you talk about like doing activities
together maybe that's one of the
activities that we could have since like
in this economy money is like a big
issue we could probably get their
parents together and have a chance every
parent's cook a different fish and then
is that way we could have the youth
perform like the best talent it could be
poetry painting drawing different kind
of wings and have like some music from
my back then in their days to radically
like well the girls are diner food will
be interacting with them in that way and
they will understand that we do care
about them excellent point anything that
will bring us together and I like the
idea of preparing and cooking for and
getting the parents of all cuz you're
right we don't want just to youth and
Elsa you want to get the parents
involved too because they're the ones
who are going to transport make sure
everything flows and works together and
get the building and and security and
safety so we want it right make sure we
have that component also but I think
that it starts simply by just an idea so
if any young person has an idea which is
what we're saying put it on a piece of
paper bring it to us because you'll have
a lot of youth groups and we're not
going to learn anything with the older
at the moment we're working everything
with you know are the youth groves and
going to this church but we have that
already let's think about reaching out
to the elderly and figuring out how to
connect with them so they want to be a
part of us because what the elderly
tummy is they're afraid of you and be
very honest they're craving I said what
do you mean by afraid they said well you
know they don't treat me well when they
see me on the street I have to like jump
over the street because you know they'll
you know bump me or that we have to talk
about that we have to think about that
because what's happening is we're
creating something that's not even true
they should not be afraid
because you want to encourage and help
them maybe they had a something a poor
outcome in it but that's just one thing
but then I said to them will tell me
about some of the good stuff in church
with your youth groups a lot of any
stories about that but that one little
insensitive in their mind we just have
to recreate that make sure we disband
that myth that the youth are someone
that can't trust when they are yes oh
yes okay just like sorry I'm going off
topic lately since now we have a new
African American president generation
how come our generation is that like
acting like that acronym so as if we
have a new president helping with that
better myself because I think that one
an excellent question one person in
office can't change all of us we have to
do it ourselves that's why remember says
livable communities that means in one
community this is what we do to empower
ourselves every community do something
differently every community has
different youth right everybody has
different issues isn't that correct but
what we have to do to represent our
president that's which one thing I know
what you're saying what you're saying is
well he's president why are we not doing
better we are doing better we have a lot
more to do don't you know don't think of
a negative we are doing a lot of great
things but we can we can move along and
move to a different way of doing things
and thinking about things so that LG and
youth can come together is that clear
okay yeah I was just going to ask do you
have
any programs or anything incorporated to
help the elderly with their medications
understanding you know this most of them
just like when they come in they're
coming in with the lives and they don't
know what they're taking for this with
that we do you incorporate anything
actually that's a good point no we
didn't um what happened was when we met
with the providers of elderly like the
children and so forth we needed to do a
lot of Education which we haven't done
yet with that group because what's
happening is every was controlling
everything in the saying we have
everything under you know everything's
fine so we don't need help with
transportation because why I provided we
don't eat help with medication because I
go with my mother's house of my day and
I give everything till Sunday so you're
right but then when we spoke to the
elder this saying well that's not really
true my kids think it's okay but I'm not
really taking it or they don't know what
they're doing so there was but they
didn't want to tell their children this
so then we went to the positions and ask
them you know could give a conversation
between you and the provider that the
children in the and you know your
patient there was resistance there also
you know the position they want to get
involved in that even with
transportation like taking a crawlway
position they want to get involved with
that so what we're trying to say is
you're right we need to figure out how
to bring everyone together because
everyone's involved just to just to
validate your point even to there's a
device that people can put by like a
LoJack for their elderly person near
Westchester had a hundred thousand of
them less than ten percent of the people
have even put got into that program so
they're going to lose the funding for
something like what so hard to get
because now it's a control thing again
where because you're not allowed to just
give someone the device of course the
child or whether the provider is that
the coming to make sure the battery
works and they don't want to do that so
that no one is in the program see so so
we still do right we're missing
something by connecting the two because
because what happened was
um the elderly person said I wanted
because I get freedom because you're not
going to say I can't go to the store
because you have to look at to find me
if I get lost or get disoriented but the
children is that I don't have time to
bring you to get the battery check
because both had to come in as a group
as a as a family I was thinking you can
get to know the birthday for any like it
what gifts and stuff take it to them and
like hang out with them and you know i
think that's that's an excellent point
because one of the things that is
missing with this generation it's not
your fault it's all fault is that you
don't know who we are so you don't know
people's stories you don't know where
they come from and I know that one of
one of the you said something about that
when we had the Black History Month and
the debate and said that well if you're
a deacon of this church or if you're a
minister you have if you should have
dinner with me once a month you should
take me out and that's not happening see
what happens is the youth groups are
separated from everyone else so they do
their own thing to go they come here
like you're here or you go to other
events but when are we getting together
with those leaders in our community and
eating with them sitting down breaking
bread with them like we used to do right
how many of us use have pastors from our
homes and have dinner or doctors or just
come to our homes and just share a meal
and then we got to know each other but
that's not happening and that's the
first step that would help us just
connect because it's not going to happen
to the elderly until we do it with those
adults and charger first I just want to
end how involved is the I guess
councilman a Councilwoman of the
district that
your show I know are there active as far
as healthy it planning for this with the
elders or do you get feedback as far as
what's going on from any of the County
Council than or anyone as far as you
know the progress of you know what's
going boy how old are they in Turkish is
the question excellent question before
election day it will comment to every
meeting okay because right we because we
started in the tempura so we had like a
few minutes every cave october became
everything that didn't this one november
then election day happen then reelection
zochor and now they haven't been to a
meeting and you know you call them so
guess what we have to keep the pressure
on them you're right because now they
are elected to do those jobs but for
some reason they were very interested
before obviously but now we have our
meetings there's less and less of them
coming and nourish l is interesting to
have six people who get elected you
counsel people and have a mayor well
these people have to come to these
meetings but what's happening is they're
not interested but what happened was
when the elderly from those districts
called then they came because we had
district 2 and 3 coal and those who live
there and know what I'm saying and then
those people come you had come to the
meeting because they cold so that's so
that goes to show you how just a phone
call or the letter can get those people
involved with your right nothing will
change until they're involved because
they controlled the one thing that we
don't have a lot of which is the money
for these programs
I thought cowboy I just want to commend
you for what you're doing and I just
want to say that I think it's very
important that the use get involved and
also their parents in the elbow News
lives I had been a lady around with
therapy for them in Melbourne and years
ago and my kids were little then I
better the store she said she had no
family and I kind of like got concerned
about her and I asked to pick her up her
house overnight bradstreet bring her out
in the weekend on the weekends we to go
out to eat my kids were with me and you
know I taught them new hammer you have
to reach out to people and make it
different like it's a moonscape I'm for
them to meet her and it was like she was
like big river and she really needed
that she had no family to move to
Florida now but she still keeps in touch
with and see hurry up or a teacher
kicked that that's it that story says
they are they in court because what
you're saying is not only did you meet
someone who would risk your life it also
enriched your children's lives and see
that's what this is all about and it can
happen so it's just a matter of us
coming together as a community now this
is a trial for AARP so you have to
support it because remember only four
areas were picked in old country to
start this because we're going to need
funding for this so we're gonna need the
state officers and we need the federal
government's get involved this because
this program is not going to run by
itself so start thinking about in your
own community what's going on with your
elderly think about do you have livable
communities there do you are we making
sure we're taking care of our elderly
and i'll be making sure that there have
been healthy are we taking care of them
we watch
are we interacting them and the most
likely and easiest way to do it is
through the youth because they want to
do it as you know President Obama said
service learning and service programs
are going to be important so when you've
give that he said they are going to be
funding for them to go to college you
know college scholarships so that's you
know that's maybe not the best way of
thinking about it but whatever we'll get
it working and then later on they'll do
it for the right reason anyway as they
always do thank you comment regarding
the killing the youth together with the
elderly the elderly are great historians
and love to share their life experiences
and stories and this is a great way of
our young people connect seen a lot of
us didn't have grandparents growing out
so they're really like to you know get
to know us into our will to share their
lives experiences with us and to teach
and this is a great way of to bridging
the generational gap and allowing our
children to experience that kind of
connection i think is
excellent and a lot of churches what
they're going to do now is they're going
to start documenting they do it here in
Columbia when you can come and you can
just you know they'll put your voice on
tape and they'll just let you tell your
story I think churches need to do that
especially when they're elderly you know
their mothers or their fathers and just
hear the stories now the children may
not think about it today but they will
they wouldn't want to go back and hear
stories about people that grow with and
never got to know because we're all here
for a limited time crying and so it's
good to have our stories carry on as
other groups to you know we took about
health disparities you're talking about
we don't tell our story so how can then
we learn to do better you know as the
doctor said okay these are the stories
now she needs everyone in here to go out
and tell this to someone else and then
someone else that I know I'm going to
tell five different people especially
what she said about the coastal earth
because you know and depends and see
there wasn't practical things that we
can tell and then we have been created a
way for what had happened today to go
further and that's the purpose of being
here so the goal this goes further not
just in the room here that we all carry
it on and the stories of the elderly are
no exception to that
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu